j'ai vraiment quelque chose à dire de
façon officielle Ron tu aurais dû te
taire et là je vais le dire devant 2
millions de
téléspectateurs vraiment tu aurais d
terire ça fait 6 mois que tu me dis
Sarah c'est quand qu'on va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dînery
vas-yi fin non non et quand il don une
date non non parce que je vais finir tu
as pas les reins pour payer mon verre à
12 € au rit c'est ça la réalité je passe
pas 12 € je passe
pas pire il donne une date la veille la
veille il trouve un mytho mais pas un
mytho
genre le mensonge qui sent la défaite et
la loose attendez les gars là les gars
minut par que
ATT
attends on va tout prendre depuis le
début on arrête tout on casse le débat
PLA direct on prend tout depuis lebut
prend tout depuis le
début vas-y raconte-moi alors qu'estce
alors raconte-moi depuis
début vous êtes
écrp mais tu veux t'assir aès de moiens
non non je vais prendre des kinex
[Rires]
pour était son mec préféré oui mais il a
il il a il a bien compris ah ouais alors
à
cô j'étais chez Jordan de luxe on me
demande mon chroniqueur préféré je dis
d'abord toi mais on me dit il est pas
chroniqueur je dis bon alors Raymon et
bah Raymon m'envoie un
texto s'il te plaît laisse laisse sa
version laisse sa version laisse sa
version vas-y vas-y vas-y alors oui il
me dit bah on se voit bientôt mais moi
j'ai dit ça oui tuas dit ça ou quelle
année tu tu veux que je je vousou mon
téléphone jeux non non on est pas là
pour faire voir
[Applaudissements]
les tout le monde commence à regarder
les téléph de ça même commencé des Jin
ça là on est en juin juillet pendant les
vacances 2023 ou tu veux que je sorte
étonnant non mais la confiance changé de
VO mon dans les aiguill alors en juillet
RAM m'appelle il me dit ouais je su je
suis dans le sud si tu veux qu'on se
voie bon mais non là il y a
av
mais non non je t'ai pas appelé pour un
pote qui divorçait qui cherchait un
avocat je dirais rien làdessus c'est le
secret professionnel je quand même
applique un truc mais je te donne la
phrase de conclusion si tu veux nous
rejoindre c'est quoi la phrase de si tu
veux nous
rejorerê là moi jeis pas non il est pas
il est pas ensuite septembre alors
septembre là tu brasses de l'air en
septembre mais mais là c'est
extraordinaire s'il vous plaît s' vous
plaît calme-toi calme-i après tu
donneris ta r Je une main courante hein
moi je fais une main courante en sortant
vasy mais le truc c'est que j'ai des
preuves donc c'est même pas de la
diffamation vasorsasy septembre est-ce
qu'on peut se voir la semaine prochaine
qui qui demande ça moi toi oui oui oui
c'est pas toi tu veux que non mais
arrête avec ton
téléphone ça àue septembre on a on a une
date Val un soir une date pas de lieu tu
es célibataire toi au moment du truc je
le suis pas Ahou d'accord ça veut dire
que maintenant ou ça l'empêche pas ça
mais lui non plus il est pas célibataire
et il me dit pas qu'il il me dit qu'il a
quelqu'un amicalement mais tout à fait
c'est pas
mal non non mais il a eu pe pense
conneries toi je suis clean il est clean
et ensuite la veille il trou te défendre
c'est pas toi c'est lui que je conneries
non non il a été très correct il m'a dit
qu'il avait quelqu'unta et ensuite il me
lâche il me laisse en remis peut-être je
sais pas bien 8h il revient avec une
excuse mais bidon dire l'excuse elle est
là je va rien tu veux vraiment que disee
tu veux vraiment que je dis vas ah non
mais il me dit Disle non non non Disle
pas c'est
quo l'événement que tu avais c'est quoi
c'est quoi l'excuse dans le votre
oreille
d'abord dit avec un smiley quand même je
m'en souviens je l' regardé avant de vir
un G dans le 12e est-ce que tu veux
venir avec moi un gala dans le 12e moi
je fais pas de gala
moi il est chanteur de
charme donc là je me dis et c'est là et
c'est là où j'en viens au au propos
terminologique que tu ne voulais pas
laissea tranquille si elle veut se faire
inviter par un homme c'est son problème
laisse là tranquille j' propos
terminologie jamais vu B non et
peut-être qu'il voulait pas payer d'où
l'invitation au Gala mais après il vous
a relancé ou pas non et il a conclu
comment le ça s'est conclu comment il
m'a lâché une vue ah ouais mais il la
ramène mois là il y a les autres hein je
suis pas tout seul moi non mais une
chape de plomb sur ce plate on t'écoute
mon tu dire c'est en vrai alors
en vrai on sa c'est vrai qu'on s'est
parlé en texto c'est vrai qu'on a dit
qu'on irait boire un verre j'ai même dit
si tu veux on va dîner en vrai le
déclencheur c'est un ami qui divorce ça
c'est pas des conneries c'est Jordan de
luxe le déclencheur dans l'émission B
oui parce qu'elle parce qu'elle a dit
qu'elle'imait bien parce que c'est après
mon ami qui a
divorcé la première fois que tu prends
contact avec Jordan le admettons que
c'est
[Applaudissements]
Jordan
im j'imagine mais s je suis atteré
saviez pas vous savez tout de votre amie
alors moi je vous jure que je savais pas
non il m'a pas dit ça tu sais qu' ah non
je sais pas il me dit pas tout donc vous
tombez vous tombez de haut là mais non
mais c'est pas de haut c'est incroyable
vous Géraldine vous le saviez ah non pas
personne SAV personne dit à personne on
savait que c'était un char mais mais il
ne m'aurait pas il aurait pas commencé à
faire l'au fusqué comme son confrère
Gill verd j'aurais rien dit d'accord
vous avez d'autres dossiers sur d'autres
personnes ici va par quoi vous tremblez
tous non qui tu as d'autres dossiers
vas-y balance tout ce soir pas grave non
Montiel en soirée très correcte ça c'est
pas la soirée du Gala on s
croisen c'est moi qui animé la soirée
doncoria si je faire un bilan des
chroniqueurs il y a que quoi des
méchanceté un peu
queon j'ai rien faire les gars non mais
non
mais et non mais à la fin à la fin à la
fin il a rien fait vous à la fin il y a
que d à la fin il y a rien du tout on sa
pas mais quand tu dis oui aller dîner
bah n'oublie pas que pendant 6 mois tu
as brassé de l'air pendant 6 mois tu as
quand même beaucoup brassé de l'air
oui après il travaille beaucoup mais
mais on devait se voir pour prendre un
verre après tu peux venir avec ton
camion de livraison quand tu es proche T
refel et on mangera un kebab dans ton
camion ah il y a une complicité il y a
quelque chose qui se passe quand même il
y a encore des FO en plus maintenant
bah
en fin de course ah ouais à cause de
Raymond non non non
non bon il y a pas d'autres chroniqueur
non mais non mais le seul qui a failli
prendre un ver avec elle c'est toiah oui
même dîner j'ai même dit même dîner j'ai
même dit viens on va dîner je crois même
un weekend même un weekend vousz sur la
rivira j'ai après l'émission cé à quelle
fin en fait vous allez à quelle fin
amicalement non non c'était amicalement
amicalement non vraiment ah vraiment
amicalement voir plus il affinité ah oui
mais non si toujours à dîner faut pas
arrêter célibataire
parce que toi tu es un sauvage tu peux
allerîner et partir et rentrer che femme
j'offre les
fleursofleur je pas droit deer AC
désintéressé il y aurait rien eu non
mais non mais on peut aller aussi dîner
avec quelqu'un sans arriû pe aller boire
ver donc là c'était vraiment tout bien
tout honneur la grande question c'est
qu'est-ce que vous lui trouvez comme
charme c'est
quoi c'est parce que je vous ai pas
désigné non pas du tout non non au
contraire ça m'intéresse il plat
énormément ce que Jordan Lux m'avait
demandé c'était qu chonqueur pr et
j'avais répondu effectivement à bout et
il m'av dit pourquoi j'avais mis la
virilité en premier voilà et c'est pour
ça tu as arrêté des pubs dans ton
émission mais Raymon c'est parce que tu
avais entendu ça que tu l'as contacé
c'est parce que tu avais entendu ça que
tu sur le ban des accusés hein je crois
pas que c'est je sais pas c'est ça il y
a une concomitance des dates en tout cas
qui est assez important devz dîner avec
quelqu'un ici ce serait Raymond bah
maintenant je vais peut-être changer
d'avis non
P pas moi ouais si Tu Vi virilité en il
va me faire payer il va me dire il va me
dire je suis sûr moi je suis persuadé
que si vous aviez été célibataire tous
les
deux alors je pense pas parce que je
suis trop honnêtement je suis trop
princesse ah ouais ouais ouais pour moi
c'est trop princesse trop princesse
ouais mais ça ça va beaucoup trop vite
je vous aurez bien vu ensemble film sur
princesse r quand même ch vu la
princesse le routi oui sur avant Noë ou
non je dirais je pense être un peu trop
princesse c'est contrairement à ce que
dit Hugo manos je l'assume et c'est vra
SOD à 12 balles je passe pas très bien
le soda à 12 balles non je passe pas qui
se passe les deux là sans déconner c'est
incroyable ch C émission cherche moi je
te propose un kebab à la tour en bas de
chez moi tu tu rempil sur le soda des
kebab tout non mais tu Prine des kebab
non justement j'en ai jamais mangé ça
sera une expérience prenez un verre tous
les deux et pu l'â de
guerre et vous savez cy
tu sais ce que je vais faire je pense
que je vais inviter Gill et c'est moi
qui vais payer ah non non non parce que
c'est vrai tuvec tu été dur avec non je
suis pas du tout vexé non avec plaisir
mais c'est moi qui invite bien entendu
oh il est mignon franchement
g pas c'est fou que vous allez vraiment
le faire ou vous faites comme Raymon je
vais
réfléchir
excuse-moi